thank you
[Music]
oh jerk
[Applause]
this week on His Radio Show Howard Stern
defended wokeism saying it's a
compliment when someone calls him woke
listen
if woke means I can't get behind Trump
which is what I think it means
or that I support people who want to be
transgender or I'm for the vaccine
dude call me woke as you want
I'm not for stupidity but I am woke
and I love it
oh dear he swore
he swore that'll win over the woke he's
a regular Huey Newton of the Hamptons
here's my theory wokism is a contagion
Stern got it from Jimmy Kimmel his new
best friend and Kimmel got it from his
wife and his wife got it from where you
get all infections a toilet seat
is very simplistic I mean it's it's like
it's not about covid jazz I didn't get
that either he was like I love the
vaccine I'm woke
okay uh if that's what he thinks it
means it's like he's like I like to be
awake so I can get more vaccines
if I sleep I don't get another booster
it's like I don't I've never heard
anybody connect woke to being vaccinated
yes even as a joke so I'm not sure where
he got that from but um if that's what
he thinks it means and that's what he
wants it to mean then I guess that's
that's great uh he's still the only guy
talking about the vaccine I know I mean
he needed to work it in there I find it
hard to believe that antifa you know is
pro-vaccinated unless it's for mange
is there a vaccine for mange I love
saying mange I don't even know what it
is Joe uh what did you think of this
reaction it's you know he's waited a
long time before he got all of his
wealth and now he's Ultra lib I I think
his definition of woke was pretty funny
it's like someone coming out and saying
if being right all the time makes me a
yeah
yes damn it I am a hero that this is not
this definition of woke it's it's if you
call someone to know it all you're not
complimenting them on the breadth of
their knowledge you're saying you don't
know as much as you think you know so
yeah woke doesn't have anything to do
with vaccines what it really means is a
sort of a slavish Devotion to left-wing
ideology and then repeating it so you
can get social credit right that's
really what it means yeah it doesn't
mean that you're smarter than anybody
and he he had said in another part of
this set because I believe in the
science well if you believed in the
science you wouldn't be hiding out like
Howard Hughes in in your Mansion so it's
it's a shame I used to be a fan of his
for me it was once he went from being a
regular guy to getting divorced and
marrying a model and hobnobbing with
celebrities and talking about how much
money he had I don't know who relates to
that and I don't relate to that any more
than someone who thinks bragging about
themselves means that they're smart and
woke it's nonsense yeah you know Tyrus
he
[Applause]
he he's collapsed for my next question
he essentially to Joe's point he flipped
he went from a populist an incredibly
popular raw populist to like the most
remote insular elitist
oh dear sweet Greg yes
y'all have never seen a villain in a
movie before
listen Howard Stern was probably the
poster child to be canceled yes his
entire radio query exploited women he
had people on with handicaps he didn't
pay he embarrassed he made people
embarrass themselves just to be on the
air he made a ton of money off it if you
talk to any of the guys that work for
him they're all broke so when you're an
evil empire guy like that and then
you're like oh yeah I'm woke I'm so woke
I'm a woke his guy you know yes he ain't
woke at all he's the most evilest guy
was like listen if I say I'm with them
they're not smart enough to figure it
out well I'm smart enough bro I know
what you're doing he's like he he
ran people into the ground embarrassed
them humiliated them a lot of them could
never get jobs again and then now he
says he's woke and even when asked what
woke is he's so arrogant he didn't even
bother look it up yeah
that's how evil he is
yeah I'm wolf
I get up at seven
I like vegetables and uh I love the
vaccine woke
you know thank God I'm not going to be
like that I'm always going to be the
same old Greg you knew way back when
as long as I keep getting that virgin
blood no Jocelyn do you miss the old
Howard Stern
well
full disclosure I'm in the running
for a hosting job on his channel
you're the best
from my potential future boss
I will say I do not consider being
called work as a compliment so Rachel
zegler who's gonna be playing the new
Snow White was seeing how um the prince
basically stalk her weird weird and all
I posted was he in stock he just
stumbled upon her in the forest and this
guy replied to my comment saying you're
so woke
I'm like what kind of weirdo definition
do you have for being woke that reciting
the facts of a known fairy tale is being
worked like to me being woke is cramming
down and ramming Ultra PC liberal
ideology down my throat and I don't let
anyone Ram anything down my throat
you know
you know uh it's great advice unless
you're planning on an endoscopy
because but you'll be unconscious for
that uh uh so you won't feel it I think
it's just all because he's he got new
friends yeah you know he got you know he
hangs out with a different group of
people and he no he's scared like Ike
Turner saying that he was for women's
rights
well I I can't come back to that one
hey Sean Hannity here hey click here to
subscribe to Fox News YouTube page and
catch our hottest interviews and most
compelling analysis you will not get it
anywhere else